good afternoon everybody
and welcome to this simultaneous meeting
of baber district
council cabinet a mid-suffolk district
council cabinet
now first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not to post comments or questions
please note that messages in the chat
panel can be viewed by people watching
the live broadcast
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of this meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i'm councillor susie morley the leader
of mid-suffolk district council
and i will be chairing this meeting
today i will now ask the governance
officer
to carry out the introductions
thank you chair in addition to the
cabinet members today
we have the following members joining us
councillor rachel ebern
councillor john field councillor sarah
mansell
councillor alastair mccraw and
councillor keith welland
officers attending the meeting are our
chief executive arthur trevonia
monitoring officer emily yule assistant
director for housing gavin fisk
the assistant director for sustainable
communities tom parker
assistant director first assets and
investments emily atack
the corporate manager for housing
solutions hebertucker
the corporate manager for strategic
housing robert hobbs and we also have
justin king from parkside housing
joining us
thank you chair
thank you very much um i'm now going to
move to the agenda thank you
we have decided to take item 10 that's
mca 20 03
which is the wool pit neighborhood plan
before the other substantive items
so i'll move now to item 1 apologies for
absence
i will now ask the governance officer to
roll call for the members present
thank you yeah members if you could uh
reply with
an indication of your presence when i
call your name thank you
uh councillor brewster present
councillor byrne present
councillor flatman present
councillor fleming
richardson we have received apologies
from and councillor whitehead
at present thank you councillor alfie
present councillor busby
present councillor davis
president councillor holt present
councillor melvisi present
councillor osborne present councillor
parker
present and council award present
thank you thank you very much item two
is to receive declarations of pecuniary
and non-pecuniary interest
by members are there any to declare
yes please counselor malvisi
yes
with respect to which item
the um disabled grants
thank you councillor thank you item
three
mca 20 0
1 is confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the mid-suffolk cabinet
meeting
held on the 7th of september 2020
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
no thank you could i have a proposal
please
i'm happy to propose the minutes um
chair thank you thank you
thank you and can i have a second to
please
sorry very pleased to a second madam
chair
thank you councillor brewster the
governance officer will now conduct the
vote
thank you chair if you could say four
against or abstain when i call your
names please
counselor brewster four councillor burn
four councillor flatman four
councillor fleming four
councillor gould four councillor
hattingham
four councillor morley four
and councillor whitehead
thank you chair that's carried thank you
item bca 20
0 1 is confirmation of the minutes of
the meeting of the baba cabinet meeting
held on the 7th of september 2020
are there any record sorry excuse me are
there any points regarding the accuracy
of the minutes
um could i have a proposal please
i'm happy to propose madam chairman it's
councillor john osborne
thank you councillor osborne and the
second of please and our second
council award thank you council award
the governance officer will now conduct
the vote thank you chair
councillor arthi four
councillor busby for councillor davis
paul councillor holt
thank you chair that's carried
thank you very much so the minutes of
both
meetings have been confirmed and will be
signed at the next practicable
opportunity item four
is to receive notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
non-received uh thank you item five
questions by councillors
nom received thank you
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny
or the joint audit and standards
committees there were none chair
thank you very much item seven is the
forthcoming decisions list does
anybody have any comments
no thank you very much so we're now
going to jump to item 10
which is mca 20 03
is the wool pit neighborhood plan and i
will now invite the mid-suffolk cabinet
member for planning to introduce this
report
counselor yeah chair if i may i'm really
sorry to interrupt
councillor malvisi can i just check your
um interest for the
disabled facilities grant item was it a
pecuniary or non-pecuniary
council of melvici just a minute um i
would class it as pecuniary
can i ask what capacity it is please
um i'm having to look at um
adaptations and
ameliorations for my 96 year old mother
okay thank you who is now in my care
okay thank you very much thank you chair
thank you very much um councillor byrne
would you like to introduce the wool pit
neighborhood plan please thank you
yes thank you chair um
the uh report before you updates cabinet
on the progress of the will put
neighborhood plan
more specifically it sets out two
recommendations
one that will pit parish council be
instructed to modify their plan
in accordance with independent examiner
recommendations
and two subject to satisfactory
completion of the above
cabinet agrees that the plan be advanced
to a local referendum
once modified the wool pit neighborhood
plan will contain some
15 policies covering housing commercial
activity
landscape connectivity and built design
paragraph 4.2 of the report
sets out the key stages prior to
examination
the examination itself is discussed in
paragraphs 4.3 to 4.5
now paragraph 4.8 you will see
confirmation
that officers are in agreement that all
the modifications should be made
at paragraph 4.11 there is
a reminder that under current government
advice
the earliest date upon which a
referendum could conceivably take place
is the 6th of may 2021
the parish council is fully aware of
this
i will now return briefly to the
examination process as i think it is
important to recognize
that in this case it did not follow the
normal pattern
at a very early stage the examiner wrote
to woolpit parish council outlining her
concerns regarding
the plan's housing strategy
this was the open letter dated 4th of
march 2020
which is now repeated as appendix 2
in the examiner's final report
the letter set out two options which the
parish council were asked
to consider first one was to proceed
with the examination
on the understanding that the examiner
would be recommending
deletion of the housing strategy policy
and accompanying site allocations
or the second option was to withdraw
the plan from examination
after careful consideration the parish
council decided not to withdraw the plan
but to proceed with the examination
that triggered the short public
consultation
on the proposed significant
modifications
that we now see in the final report
in this the examiner also clearly
acknowledges
that the changes proposed may not be
welcomed by
all but she goes on to say that this is
an excellent
plan with a comprehensive range of
policies
which will be very valuable for guiding
the location and scale of future
new housing development since
publication of the examiner's report
your neighborhood planning officer
has been in contact with and has met
both the chair and the clerk of warping
parish council
i am told that those discussions have
been of a positive nature
and that the parish council also
recognizes the greater benefit to be
gained
from having an adopted neighborhood plan
in place
before i finish i ask that our officers
continue to work with the parish council
and that they provide whatever technical
support is needed to ensure that a
referendum
version of a woolpit neighborhood plan
can be made available at the earliest
opportunity
i also ask our officers to publish the
necessary decision statement
which will confirm our intention to take
the neighborhood plan
to a local referendum and so i do ask
that the cabinet
endorse the recommendations before them
and they look for a second thank you
and can i have a second to please uh jim
i'm happy
to very happy to second uh the
recommendations at three one and three
two
thank you very much councillor brewster
um
before i go into questions and
then debate i'm just going to invite the
ward member counselor mansell to say a
few words
counselor mansell uh um i've just put my
video on as well as my mic so hopefully
you can see me
uh thank you very much for giving me the
opportunity to
uh speak about the woolpit neighborhood
plan
um now it's been a somewhat um up and
down journey
since the uh neighborhood plan area was
designated back in 2016
and i fully understand the difficulties
about the numbers of proposed housing uh
within wool pits
and the fact that it did not uh concur
with the draft joint local plan
um and of course i think part of the the
whole
um uh story of wall pit neighborhood
plan
is one of timing really and and the fact
that the the the timings were sort of
out of sync with the joint local plan
and the numbers
uh that woolpit neighborhood plan were
working with
did not match the ones uh for the joint
local plan um
and there was a delay between the two
publications
uh i also share the many frustrations uh
of
both the neighborhood plan steering
group and i'm sure
several of the um residents of woolpit
um whose aim was really about preserving
the rural nature and the historic
significance of
of woolpit which which i believe is one
of the most iconic villages within our
district
um but but we have to also congratulate
the
uh neighborhood plan working group uh
who has
have gone through a considerable amount
of work to get this far
um and and when i read through the
offices uh the examiner's report um i
felt that there were
a lot of changes not not just the one
about the housing
policies and the allocations there do
seem to be
a number of suggested amendments by the
examiner
but as as mentioned already by
councillor byrne
the examiner did clearly state that it
is essentially
a very good plan it does contain a
number of policies which will help shape
uh future development in warpit um so
uh and i it is also my understanding
that will pit
parish council um are prepared to make
this recommendation recommended changes
albeit somewhat reluctantly um because
obviously
you know they they realize the benefits
of wool pit having a neighborhood plan
albeit it may not be the one that they
first set out to
to create um of course this neighborhood
plan
if you um uh go along with your
recommendations today
uh it will still have to go through the
reference referendum
uh and that really is it it could go
either way
i i don't know which way uh the people
with good people of woolpit are likely
to vote
um and but i you know i really hope
having put all this work into it
that it is supported by the majority of
the
um residents and of course due to the
covet restrictions the date of this
referendum
uh we still have no idea when it's
likely to be and it's going to be some
way off
um but i really do hope that eventually
woolpit neighborhood plan
uh does become adopted as part of our
planning policy
uh and i just felt that it was um it was
important for
for there to be some representation of
the community um
in these tricky times so i i do
fully support uh the recommendation by
uh for the cabinet to to allow
woolpit neighborhood plan to go on to
the next stage albeit
with some indeterminate um timeline so
thank you very much um for allowing me
to
to speak thank you councilmember
so we're now going to move into
questions from mid-suffolk
members um if i just go through you
through each in turn if you could
indicate whether you have a question you
would like to ask
councillor brewster
councillor byrne
now i have no questions thank you
councillor flatman
no questions at this time thank you
chair councillor fleming
no questions thank you chairman
councillor gould
no questions thank you councillor
hadingham
no questions thank you i have no
questions
and councillor whitehead no questions
jack
does any other um
counselor present wish to ask a question
nope thank you so it's counselor morally
sorry
it's counsellory burn here i did have my
hand raised but oh i'm i'm terribly
sorry
oh sorry yeah yes you're right
ask your question counselor um thank you
very much chair um
but firstly i'm a bit confused by the
agenda because i think people
if if anyone will people have been
looking at this agenda they'd have
wondered why it was in a
confidential set section of the agenda
so um i think that's a shame that that
mistake was made
but um my i've got two questions if i
may
um and one is
that we've had some issues with
neighborhood plans um within planning
committees
so could i ask what training there will
be for members
um on the policies within this
neighborhood plan when it goes to
referendum
and for other neighbor plans that are
due to go to referendum
please and secondly um
i was just wondering if someone could
explain in more detail
the issues about the
timings and housing numbers for this
plan
councillor byrne referred to an early
stage letter in march 2020
but that was over a year after woolpit's
own consultation on their neighbor plan
so
i don't really call that early and the
actual numbers
are there's 727
within the draft emerging joint local
plan
um and that was released we we only
approved it as a council in july 2019
again which was after
um the wool pit's own consultation
and those numbers are
um supposed to be um
based on new development locations and i
i didn't think they were supposed to be
based on
every single land allocation um put
forward for the
plan or the majority and that those
numbers at 727
are significantly greater than debenhams
at 278
and stradbrokes at 282 for a similar
sized village
so i just wondered chair if i could
possibly have some
clarification on that thank you very
much indeed for allowing me to ask
questions
thank you councillor eben councillor
byrne would you like to answer the
question or bring in your
assistant director
um yes
thank you uh i'll try to answer
the training one it is it is true that
we
um are having quite a lot of
neighborhood plans coming through
uh at the moment and there are more in
the pipeline
uh and it is obviously necessary for
uh councillors planning committee
members etc to
to keep up to speed with um
those plans and their relationship to
our other development development
management plans
um and so i think we do
we do have um
some expectation
of of training for members
specifically on that on that particular
point i have
asked for uh training um
for neighborhood plans and relationship
with local plan
to be uh to be brought forward for for
members
i can't tell you at this stage when that
might be
on the other on the other questions yes
i will bring in
my um assistant director
uh for that one if he's available
um if not i think we have uh
um rob hopes with his strategic planning
um a corporate manager but uh
tom would you be available to
answer the council events other
questions please
um i am available and i am i'm here with
you in the meeting i
think though that it would be more
beneficial for councillors you'll get
more detail
um from robert hobbs who's been more
intimately involved with the
housing numbers um and the the way that
the
responses were provided to wallpaper and
the
plan making progressed so if i can hand
over to
robert hobbs your corporate manager for
strategic planning
i think that will provide more detail
for councillors
thank you okay thank you tom
um yeah if i can just confirm that the
the preferred options um joint local
planned version is the published
position
which sets out the um the number 727
and that came after the regulation 14
consultation on the wool pit neighbor
plan but it did
come before the plan was submitted for
the regulation 16 consultation so there
was ample opportunity
for the regulation 14 plan to be
revisited
in terms of the numbers in comparison
with debenham and stradbroke
the joint local plan sets out a spatial
strategy for the district
across district-wide to meet the
district white housing needs
and um as a result of that um
bull pit is within the transport
corridor
um and that is to keep one of the key um
areas of the spatial distribution within
the joint local plan
as opposed to stradbroke and um devon
that i mentioned
thank you very much thank you councillor
byrne
thank you does anybody else have any
questions
um could i could i just uh um complete
an
answer for uh council eben
where she was talking about the length
of time that it took for
the deficiency if i can call it that
of the original um wool pit plan
was brought to their attention um
she quoted the date of march 2020 that
examiner's open letter has been
that was not the first occasion on which
the the drawback had been noticed
in october 2019 we ourselves
submitted written representation to the
examiner which whilst acknowledging
that many of our regulation 14 stage
comments had been taken on board
the single critical issue of housing
numbers and methodology
had not been assessed so addressed sorry
so um it was it didn't take quite as
long as
as you were thinking can cerebral
thank you thank you for that counselor
thank you so i'm now going to open up
the item for debate
and i'll go through again each of you in
turn
counselor brewster
sorry no chair i have
nothing at this time thank you council
bern
[Music]
um no i think i've i've said all i have
to say
except um in my opinion i've yet to find
a circumstance
uh in which a neighborhood plan
is not better than no neighborhood plan
so i would urge the presidents of war
pit
to backless when the appropriate time
comes
thank you councillor bern councillor
flatman no thank you chair
councillor fleming no thank you
councillor gold simply to say that i'm
pleased to hear that the um the
parish council has agreed to
proceed with the examiner's
recommendations
and i think that's a positive uh very
positive response
thank you thank you very much councillor
hadingham
um no comment thank you
councillor whitehead i'm happy with the
report so
no further comment to make thank you
very much
um i will now ask the governance officer
to conduct the vote
thank you chair councillors when i call
your name if you can answer four against
or abstain
councillor brewster four
councillor ban whoa also flatman
four councillor fleming four
councillor gould four councillor
hattingham
four councillor morley four
councillor whitehead four
thank you chair that's carried thank you
very much everybody
so now moving on to item eight
or as i should say back to item eight
which is the resolution to exclude the
public
uh which terms includes the press and
that is to consider whether in pursuant
to part one of schedule 12a
of the local government act 1972
the public should be excluded from the
meeting for the business specified below
on the grounds that if the public were
present during these this item
it is likely that there will be
disclosure to them of exempt
information as indicated against each
item
the author of the report proposed to be
considered in part two of the agenda is
satisfied that the public interest in
maintaining
the exemption outweighs the public
interest in disclosing
the information so can i please ask for
a proposal and a seconder from
mid-suffolk
i'm happy to propose that it's
councillor hattingham thank you
councillor
and a seconder and i'm happy to um
second the proposal
chair thank you very much and can i have
a proposer and a second different baby
thank you i'll propose from baber
council award
thank you councillor madam chairman
councillor jenn osborne
thank you councillor osborne
governance officer will now conduct the
vote thank you chair
councillor brewster
four sorry councillor ban
four councillor flatman four
councillor fleming paul councillor gould
four councillor hattingham four
councillor morley four councillor
whitehead
four thank you councillor alfie
four councillor busby
councillor davis poor councillor halt
four councillor melvisi
councillor osborne four councillor
parker
paul council award four
thank you chair i will now ask rob
to stop the live stream he'll confirm
once that's been done
you